kourtney kardashian and travis barker
just upgraded their status from
boyfriend girlfriend to fiances and now
a source is telling e.t how her ex scott
disick feels about it quote scott is
stewing over courtney and travis's
engagement and not happy at all he's
lonely right now and not in a
relationship and is very jealous that
things are working out for courtney life
is a challenge of course court and scott
share three children together
eleven-year-old mason nine-year-old
penelope and six-year-old reign and e.t
source explains that scott would prefer
to go back to when they were just
getting along as co-parents without
anyone else in their lives romantically
quote he's trying to figure out his next
move when it comes to their kids the two
have been pretty amicable over the years
and seem to put their little ones first
in fact back in 2019 court sister chloe
praised the couple for their
co-parenting skills during a chat with
e.t i think they're doing amazing and i
think everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but my mom and my dad were like
that it took them years but my dad would
come over once a week for family dinners
and would play golf with my stepdad and
so we come from a family where we
believe in that and you share children
with people and that's how it should be
it's a beautiful thing to get along as
for court e.t source says she's trying
to ignore any negativity from scott
she has been down that road too many
times to count and is just enjoying this
moment i've seen it all fans will recall
that during the keeping up with the
kardashians finale that aired in june
scott gave the push founder his blessing
to move on romantically i think if you
really love somebody right like you want
them to be happy no matter what
so i do give her a blessing to be happy
but things went south in september when
scott was publicly called out by
courtney's other ex eunice benjamin for
allegedly dming him some not-so-nice
comments about courtney and travis's
pda-filled vacation a separate source
previously told et quote courtney and
scott are definitely not as close as
they once were scott has some unsettled
ill will towards courtney and travis
being together and courtney is over the
jealousy she thinks scott needs to grow
up i'm not putting my energy there
meanwhile the father of three has
seemingly remained close with the
kardashian family earlier this month he
was spotted with chloe attending the
saturday night live after party in new
york city following kim's hosting gig
travis baby oh i have to do my show
i can't help it your honor oh my god did
you just call me your honor
yeah babe baby baby and when it comes to
courtney and travis the two appear to be
on cloud nine after the blink 182
drummer popped the question over the
weekend on a rose-covered beach in
montecito california and while scott may
not be thrilled by the news according to
e.t source the rest of the family is
quote their families are beyond happy
and excited for them their kids are very
much looking forward to being an
official big happy family
you